Một thật tư, anh cho rằng của quả nhà có thể trở thành một nhân tố quan trọng trong lực có thể nhằm bảo đam ăn ninh tại nhà biệt hòa mốt.
Trong bối cảnh, đến vật tại năng lượng chính lực này đang bị giảm đoạn như trọng.
Bốt trường có lực lượng bũ trang anh, anh, anh, anh, anh, anh, anh, anh, anh, anh, anh, anh, anh.
Mạnh, của quảnh sẽ yếu năng lực công nghệ phần sức đặc biệt là mấy bây giờ không nghĩ là thục nhóm tiến tiến hàng đầu phy giới,
và đã chúng mình hiệu qua trong thử chiến bao gồm và biệt lối phó với ua về xa hết của yên răng tại chúng đông.
Lần đồn hiện đang khối hơn với hơn bao mấy cú ra để tiêm kiểm giải pháp khối phục lưu thông tại ở biệt hòa mốt.
Trong khi kiét đã tham gia tham vấn và chiến khai hương hai trong chuyên gia tới khu hực nhằm hỗ trợ bảo vệ đuễn hàng hải này.
Pháp được cũng ngay tổng thống quả nhà của bố lực đia xíu trọng biết,
hương này sẽ sản xàng chia sẻ kinh nghiệm tá chiến,
đông thời đu quả nghiệm đẩy máy xức khẩu của mẹ có phòng để tận giúp lúc gồm ra tăng cho bố kèng an ninh bọn gồm nhiều biến đốc.